j'ai été formé comme un shooter en
matière tactique majeur c'est formateur
de tirs d'armes à feu
formateur de techniques de défense
policière
un policier d'élite dotée d'une
expérience d'enquêteurs issus de la
communauté mohawk
une perle rare que la grc a recruté en
2017 au sein de sa nouvelle brigade de
lutte au crime organisé en milieu
autochtone imprima place assez
rapidement
je m'entendais bien avec les gens dans
son livre ce qui travaillait pour moi
autant que les auteurs aient poussé à
l'emploi de la grc depuis une quinzaine
d'années jérémy tomlinson n'avait appris
à composer avec les blagues de mauvais
goût sur les autochtones et les préjugés
sur l'alcoolisme et les exemptions de
taxes il croyait que ce serait différent
dans sa nouvelle équipe b ça a été pire
je donne un exemple de haine qui se
passe est souvent un individu on a lens
reims et la bouche avec du rêve bush
faisait souvent une farce qui sont allés
prendre un shooter autochtone d'entendre
ça de jour en jour ou bio à aubure roule
dans un arc dans un beau dans le fossé
sur les communautés autochtones déplaise
à au cours des mois suivants son unité
planifie l'arrestation de trafiquants de
drogue dans un village maroc
le caporal tomlinson juge que les moyens
déployés pour cette opération sur des
mesures et il le fait savoir à son
superviseur dans l'eau comme noter si
vous allez avec les hélicos les quelques
blindés
vous allez réveiller toute la population
parce que la crise d'oka brésil on n'a
pas encore 30 ans plus tard jérémy
apprend par la suite que sa prise de
position a été très mal reçue par ses
patrons on questionnait mon allégeance
cg terre au lycée ou si j'étais un de
ses poteaux qu'est-ce qui passe elle je
peux m'en débarrasser mais enfin la
cadec les morgans et alors là ce qu'ils
pensaient que c'est un criminel
le contentieux s'amplifie on lui
reproche ensuite d'avoir réclamé sans y
avoir droit
le remboursement de repas d'une valeur
de 17 dollars des collègues de son
équipe ont fait la même erreur
il est pourtant le seul à se voir
imposer une sanction de 12 jours sans
salaire et d'une interdiction de
promotion pour deux ans par son
commandant jérémy tomlinson porte
plainte pour harcèlement
ça plaît tu es rejeté par le même
commandant il ya comme une normalisation
duras compte les autochtones en direct
initialement les perd 5 entre 2017 et
2019 jérémy tomlinson a dû subir
plusieurs interrogatoires dans une de
ces rencontres en mars 2010 9e
l'enquêteur remettent en question son
allégeance à la grc
interview vous obtenez manque jusqu'à
maman comme ça va pas changer parce que
je travaille pour la grc
c'est un motif de discrimination prévu
évidemment à la charte et aux lois qui
s'appliquent donc c'est évident que
cette question-là doit pas faire l'objet
normalement nos discussions des changes
de colportage ont déterré au type parce
que c'est ça la discrimination à c'est
ça le harcèlement c'est comme si les
autochtones
on a un statut spécial que c'est correct
de poser des questions comme farfelu
c'est correct d'impôt aux épisodes à
fort sur les autos parce que c'est comme
si on est un fléau dans le soap europe
c'est comme les différents de rats
pendant quatre ans le caporal tomlinson
croyait avoir en sa possession tous les
documents concernant ses litiges avec
son employeur à ton avis tout un été
transmis dans ce qui était fait nous
avons appris grâce aux témoignages
d'employés de la grc qui souhaite taire
leur identité qu'un rapport d' enquête
crucial le concernant a été modifié à la
demande d'un patron de l'organisation
dans ce rapport des éléments qui
remettent en cause la crédibilité des
supérieurs immédiats du caporal
tomlinson ont été retirés de la version
finale
c'est vraiment c'est déplorable c'est
pas comme quoi plus dire que je reproche
aux organisations une gestion qui a non
seulement ignoré tout cet environnement
toxique le de commentaires déplacés
commentaires racistes et on laisse ses
services pas nécessairement l'encourager
mais quand une ligne or quand tu le
caches courage c'est certain que le type
de contrôle du comportement que vous
décrivez laissent place à des
questionnements et et dans une
organisation qui constateraient des
agissements comme cela il y aurait
nécessité d'intervention
jérémy tomlinson est en congé maladie
depuis presque deux ans ils réclament
des dédommagements financiers pour la
perte d'une promotion qui lui avaient
été attribuées mais qu'il n'a pu obtenir
à la suite des sanctions imposées par
son commandant moi oui ça l'est entre
temps il consacre une bonne partie de
son temps à des activités culturelles et
sportives dans sa communauté d'origine
j'ai été demandé à plusieurs reprises
par les enfants c'est un cadeau de 7 en
organique
cécile bobo par tonne en bois c'est
pourquoi pourquoi tu es plus un policier
c'est une question comme présente parce
que moi je veux pas que mes enfants à
une peine pour d'autres gens mais je
leur dis quoi par exemple parce qu'une
réalité que molly fait face que d'autres
ont fait face puisque avons première
phase
quand ils vont grandir
[Musique]